i am so excited right now because we
have a huge announcement
are you all ready buckle up and
that's a pun intended because we're
taking the drew marymore show
on the road with the coast-to-coast trip
along the iconic
route 66 from california to
new york city and we've enlisted this
very special couple
to help us make this journey and here is
the story of
karen and noah then a clawson
hi i'm karen and i'm noah we've got two
great kids
an amazing golden doodle and five
chickens and we are
the founders of musing co outdoors a
sprinter van conversion company in
oakland california
in march of 2020 we finished a really
large project and boom
just absolutely blindsided by the
pandemic and then all of a sudden it
just hit like a freight train but we
spent three days going oh my gosh
we just had to close everything um what
do we do we looked around and
realized we actually had a couple
delivery vans that just happened to be
sprinter vans
activated the design team remotely and
we designed one
karen and i took the thing and headed up
the coast with the kids
people would come up to us they were
flocking to the van and we
realized how much interest there was in
these and it just
absolutely built a love for travel that
both in recreation and business
i just started to realize how big the
world is and develop
absolute love for it traveling to the
next state can be an eye-opening
adventure
you're seeing something new that you've
never seen before and that to me is
really the power of the travel
experience
we are so unbelievably excited to be
heading out on the road for you and
can't we see you in a few days they are
it's karen and noah they're joining us
before they hit the road
hi guys how are you doing
hi drew it's so nice to meet you oh
thank you guys so much
for doing this with us i am just
so glad that you guys are representing
that lifestyle and talking about
the whimsy and the wonder of how
extraordinary
life in this sprinter van can be
it is it's limitless you know it's it's
so amazing just to pull in
anywhere you want you don't you're not
even bound by campgrounds you just kind
of pull in wherever you want
it's amazing okay where are you guys now
and when do you leave
yeah so greetings from oakland
california um that's where we
are from that's where uh the company is
and
um we're leaving after this too we are
getting on the road as soon as we hang
up with you we are
quite literally heading off across the
country we'll see you in nine days
i'm excited you're about to hit the road
karen who will you be meeting along the
way
um we are going to be doing a barrymore
tour
at tries location i'm not going to give
it away
but i will say it might be just a tad
scary
but it might also be amazing um
oh i i am too believe me
um we're going to be meeting with some
really inspiring drew gooder
um and then of course we're going to be
checking in with
a small business owner um and
celebrating the amazing job that they've
done
keeping themselves and their employees
afloat during this whole pandemic and
we're going to do more we'll share it
all with you when we get there
well over the next nine days we're going
to be with you checking in
as you make your way here to the show in
new york
that's right that's the end destination
i'll be here
with open arms and uh if you spot the
drew van
in your town be sure to take a photo
and send it to the show or post it on
social media
and you just might see your picture
on the air that's right because we're
going to show some of these pictures
i'm going to feature some on my social
media by the way did you guys get some
of the drew's news stickers too
do you have those yeah we did and
they're already
getting stuck okay perfect all over for
people to find
i love seeing stickers and i feel like
it's a lost art so we printed a bunch of
drew's new stickers
so if you see those around tag us too
all right karen and noah
then aclawson safe travels with you on
the road
we will be here waiting but checking in
with you all along the way and
seriously if you spot that drew van let
us know thank you drew we're so excited
we're so excited to get there thank you